kate beckinsale was almost Diana
Princess of femme Oseary
can you say that in a new interview with
variety the 45 year old reveals that she
was merely cast as the leading lady in
Wonder Woman a part that eventually went
to gal gadot it's been kind of a wild
ride quote there was a period of time a
long time ago when producer Joel Silver
was involved with the film but it worked
out beautifully that was a wonderful
film that gal did it's incredible that
this character had been around for 75
years and we only now get to tell her
origin story it's crazy and I think that
everything that she stands for is just
so relevant she's all about love and
compassion and equality and acceptance
and we really need that now Beckinsale
ended up loving the final version of the
flick something she doesn't think would
have happened if the original script had
been made
she explained quote it would have been a
terrible movie based on the script that
I read Beckinsale also revealed whether
she's open to reprising her role as
Selene for another underworld movie it
is a wid thing to kind of get back into
the exact same outfit quote I wouldn't
return I've done plenty of those
meanwhile the Wonder Woman franchise is
gearing up for a sequel of its own so
many people care so much for this
character and and you do feel the
responsibility of this iconic you know
biggest character and at the end of the
day I just gotta forget about that and
just focus on what I need to do best
which is acting and actually you know
tell her story in the most interesting
original way I can think of ET caught up
with the movie's director patty Jenkins
and Godot earlier this year and they
revealed that the upcoming film won't be
like the first so we're actually making
a totally different film with a lot of
the same
similar like things that we love but
it's a it's it's own movie completely so
it's not to anything to us yeah to us
it's an entirely new adventure together
that were couldn't yeah it's almost when
I whenever I hear Wonder Woman - I'm
like yeah jelly's cover this yeah
[Music]